[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
amber heard sucks now i'm not talking
about how she gets acting gigs i'm
talking about her as a wife
i would rather be married to a
fleshlight stuffed with barbed wire than
that aqua [ __ ] there are abortion
doctors that have drained less life out
of people
she crushed johnny depp's career so fast
they should call her cucci astro world
lied about abuse to destroy him this
busty smellet is more toxic than a
two-week-old tampon or as they call him
south of the border menstrualtas
now before you go out there thinking
johnny depp is this innocent victim
remember it takes two durango
i mean being married to johnny isn't
easy he's a walking wine glass that's
had more bumps in a braille library and
listen you should never hit a woman
which is why what amber did to johnny is
so wrong
that being said if you're from kentucky
and speak with a fake british accent and
dress like a fentanyl fortune teller you
deserve to get punched in your [ __ ]
face johnny's more full of [ __ ] than his
sheets
johnny quit crying about your bed
already your wife took a dump big deal
it happens to the best of us who's the
bad guy in all of this is it amber is it
johnny or is it us i mean they're airing
their dirty laundry and we're sniffing
it up like a japanese businessman
i guess the only thing that we can say
is arigato doug stanhope knows her his
dan helps stan helps buddies with uh
johnny depp
and he wrote something about you know
like i forget what he wrote i think he
wrote like a little essay about how full
of [ __ ] she is and she threatened to sue
him and i think he had to wind up taking
it down i hope i'm not [ __ ] that up
but uh he knows her he knows her well
and he's like she's out of her [ __ ]
mind and i'm like like like a crazy
actress he's like yeah like those are
real
of course there's a ton of them there's
a lot of them that's why they're good
that is why they're good doug stanhope
put something up
he wrote something he's friends with uh
johnny depp and he's going through this
brutal [ __ ] divorce
and uh i just want to give him props
for sticking up for his friend and
everything and saying something because
you know you know what's really so
[ __ ] up
all right
it's all the [ __ ] that happens to women
that guys do women is [ __ ] up but
there has been a slight over correction
now where if somebody a woman just says
you do something
before you're ever tried or convicted it
just gets put in the paper
it gets put all over the internet and
then all you [ __ ] morons or ninety
percent of you on the [ __ ] internet
just take it as truth
take it as fun why do you take it as
truth
because you want it to be true because
he's doing better than you in life i
mean
it's [ __ ] unbelievable i i really
believe this okay if somebody gets
accused
okay
of of of rape or domestic violence they
should not publicize the person's name
until they're convicted of it i think
that's more than fair
considering all the [ __ ] dopes out
there that the second they read
something it's gonna be true
you know
let it [ __ ]
see what happens first
see what the [ __ ] happens first oh that
that whole thing now that all you got to
do is just say the amount of [ __ ]
guys who've been falsely accused of that
[ __ ] it's like you're literally [ __ ]
with their ability to get a job
you're [ __ ] with their reputation you
know the deal dude
like domestic violence and anything
involving sex that [ __ ] never goes that
never goes away um
so i don't know i just want to you know
give stan hope [ __ ] props for
actually sticking up for the guy because
there's a lot of people
you know because of the stigma around
that even if they know it isn't true
they're afraid to throw their hat in the
[ __ ] ring
right now i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened or whatever okay i'm just
saying the fact that somebody finally
just said hey this guy hasn't been tried
for anything yet he's a friend of mine i
know he would never do this it was it
was refreshing trust me when i say you
do not want to do a trial when a guy
who's gonna be on the stand is acting in
his corner
cause the dude knows you know what he
knows see you see amber heard in the
[ __ ] box and [ __ ] you see her behind
the desk and she's all
uh
like she can't
she thinks she's acting but johnny depp
knows something that she doesn't
stillness
dude you see how he's serving the
[ __ ] lawyers
the lawyer come up and they're all cocky
you know her hollywood shits well didn't
you say this and he goes like this
yes
okay but then this and that's what you
said right
yes
okay and again you said this
for the third time yes
okay and then okay and then that's this
right that's when you said this
i'm sorry you're asking about which one
you're asking about
the other
a different thing or the same three
things you just asked for the fourth
time yes okay
oh dude and the courtroom goes like this
everyone in the courtroom like this
i'm in the quorum like this
poor johnny depp i feel bad for the
[Applause]
the only good thing is everybody knows
now and this is a good thing this is one
of the reasons why it's good that you
did this everyone knows now like there's
something wrong with her yeah like
there's something wrong right there's
some sort of like
mental issue whatever well there's a lot
of mental issues and you said she [ __ ]
in his bed see i didn't say that they
said that who's they the people on the
news
[Laughter]
well they're always right
that's what i found out the last year
okay so they said that she [ __ ] in his
bed for what reason mark territory
johnny depp testifies
ate a cheesy gordita crunch from taco
bell
breaking news
i'm glad dude so many guys are getting
accused of this [ __ ] so many guys
are getting accused of this stuff and
everyone's scared to speak out and
johnny depp is just like i've got 800
million dollars i've got the time
i am not in two franchises anymore
play the whole recording everyone
in the jury
this was still he's got acting in the
corner am i crazy to say her stock went
up whoa yeah am i crazy to say hold on
johnny
crazy crazy the stock went up after
severing a guy's finger her stock went
up went up how because he stayed he
didn't leave shut off the bed stayed
there
over here he's being able to being
abused no no no he walks into his room
and his wife is [ __ ] on the bed okay
after he showed up late to her 30th
birthday or something like that i don't
like that you made it sound like that's
a normal thing to do [ __ ] the bed is
abnormal behavior okay yo shut the [ __ ]
up
sometimes you [ __ ] the bed okay listen
all i'm saying is [ __ ] the bed looked at
her and was like not i got to get out of
here he's like how can i make this work
how can we go to therapy how can we
figure this out because the [ __ ] neck
is crazy he was willing to leave he's
crazy he what do you say in the text
i knew that was crazy what do you say in
the text what
uh other uses for your throat that do
not include injury
that's fine
yeah yeah what are they
i don't know
i describe it
yeah we need to do it
her [ __ ] is [ __ ]
her [ __ ] is [ __ ]
yourself you're saying it's the biggest
fluff of yourself myself i'm a happily
married man
no no you [ __ ] in the bed ruining me you
shoot in the bed and now you're trying
to justify like oh yeah my dick's fire
that's what my girl stole my drink i
just pulled my neck my dick is fine i
just put my whole neck i'm not gonna be
able to do the podcast my whole neck is
just pulling i didn't sign up for some
uh huma to watch a human pain yeah i
didn't sign up for that i won millions
of dollars yeah just like um amber hurt
did yeah
um so she basically took off her uh your
boots basically
she took off my boots without your
consent yeah that was one of the things
that that um johnny depp described
as being why
amber heard
is a monster yeah because when he would
come home
she would take off his boots and hand
him a glass of wine that doesn't sound
like a monster to me that sounds like a
good submissive asian woman
yeah that sounds like a concubine yeah
that sounds like a woman who gets it
yeah i mean maybe he was on drugs didn't
appreciate the fact that she probably
[ __ ] his brains out yep she took his
boots off she handed him wine and
occasionally threw a bottle of vodka at
her yeah but that comes with the
territory the territory yeah you know
you can't pray for rain and not deal
with the money you're not going to get
your boots taken off and not get a
bottle of vodka thrown at you yeah yeah
i mean when you get your boots taken off
in new york city it's because you got
knocked out on the 12 train you know
that's why that yeah you get timberlands
stolen off your feet uh for and your
christmas money which happened to me
once when i was a kid yeah it's the
whole johnny depp thing is just
he was famous when he was 20 and i don't
think you get any kind of perspective
like that i think you're [ __ ]
it's like it's like making cement but
you don't add in all the ingredients and
it's like oh it never cured right yeah
well i i mean johnny dep what happened
he looks
it's rough it's 55 years of coke
[Laughter]
he's not 75. he looks great for what
he's doing he's like 60 right
we have it that he started after he
started doing cooking
how old is johnny's up
he's got to be 60.
what is it 58 58 50. he looks like it's
55 years of doughnuts coke it would make
you look thin and well he's not athletic
he's not like working out yeah he's not
taking care of himself and for a long
time at least he smokes cigarettes i
don't know if he still does but
all those factors
they contribute to poor health
he's he the outfits aren't great either
where is she shopping yeah he's uh
both of them right yeah she's copying
him supposedly she like mimics his
outfits
i don't know it was it was good to see
and of course it was stanhope stanhope
stanhope's a good [ __ ] man um
um as is johnny depp by the way a few
times he's he's a big stand-up fan he
comes out to shows he's [ __ ] humble
as hell
you know gentle one of the most gentle
[ __ ] people ever you know what i mean
look listen to me listen how the [ __ ] i
talk you know what i mean
you'd understand it if it came you know
somebody said that about me that he
[ __ ] snapped like posey and [ __ ]
dirty doesn't
i know i barely know the guy i've only
met him a few [ __ ] times but like i
don't i really
tend to believe
what the [ __ ]
stan hope is saying and i 100 believe
that you should not be putting
somebody's [ __ ] name out there just
because somebody said it
you know
oh it's [ __ ] um but this [ __ ]
state is brutal she's going for [ __ ]
spousal support you know going for
[ __ ] spousal support which means he's
got to pay her for like the rest of her
[ __ ] life she married the guy for 15
[ __ ] months and you know what kills
me about that person she's gonna [ __ ]
go to the beyonce concert right all the
is independent he said well you watch
her throw a [ __ ] hand up
oh that [ __ ] gets me heated all right
here we go here we go is there any
[ __ ] ribbons from for guys falsely
accused of rape and domestic violence
you know is do they get their month
you know will the nfl wear a color for
them of course they won't they don't
they don't give a [ __ ]
yo amber [ __ ] what's her last
name heard
her
why she don't need to last that's amber
right that's amazing honestly you get an
amber alert in your phone i get excited
the hurricane coming
i know you looked at your phone you see
some ugly ass kid like
yeah amber alert two kids gone johnny
depp's
that's the emperor alert is your
family's done if that [ __ ]
oh my god your family's done yeah yeah
if amber come around your family's
i'm sorry
i love how they [ __ ] tried to show
johnny depp's text messages in the court
like it was evidence against him he was
texting with like paul bettany which is
hilarious that he was texting with paul
bettany by the way
and and he was just texting like how
[ __ ] callan and i would text like oh
no she's a she's a i think she's a witch
and paul that and he's like no she's
probably not a witch he's like we should
burn her at the stake shouldn't we ha ha
and he's like no we shouldn't and then
the [ __ ] lawyer does it all out of
context and he's just like so you're
admitting that amber you think amber
heard was the soulless witch and i'm
sorry but you wanted to burn her at the
stake and johnny depp is just like
it wasn't just what's happened
so still
this guy acting in this corner
[Music]
dude he [ __ ] master there should be
master class in court with johnny
with johnny depp dude master class they
have a martin scorsese for directing
[ __ ] uh some race car driver for
drifting and then johnny depp for in
court master class
hi class i'd like to tell you first of
all we'd like to teach the first thing
which is stillness don't move unless you
have to and wear a bug on your tie
that's step two imagine what a slow week
for news
then newsweek is like [ __ ] syria
forget about the ukraine
let's let's find out children's
hospitals being blown up in ukraine but
let's find out if she [ __ ] in his bed
look at him i'm on my side of the bed
was human fecal matter
let me hear how he says it
it wasn't a good time human fecal matter
jesus christ
so i understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
she was sitting on one side
of the couch i was sitting on the other
she that's when she was trying to
explain
a few things about coachella and
then the fecal
[Music]
delivery
and say saying that it was the dog
and i i could i'm sorry i could not
agree with her i've lived with those
dogs i
picked up their fun
it was not
the dogs
look at his face first of all he's this
is a big win for johnny depp and a big
loss with pirates of caribbeans how
about [ __ ] you guys you got rid of the
best [ __ ] pirate you've ever had for
a crazy lady
you [ __ ] up fecal delivery the
vehicle delivery
daddy i just made fecal delivery
can you change me
what's fecal delivery that's a nice way
of staying in court she [ __ ] the bed
because you can't say that i made a
fatal delivery what happens if you said
she [ __ ] in my bed in court
did they kick you out did they get mad
at you she made
in my bed i bet you could say dump she
dumped excuse me
objection
[Laughter]
the defendant is using slang she [ __ ]
[ __ ] in my bed yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
in my bed did you see him smirking
that's what made me laugh so hard yeah
we might be underestimating amber we
haven't even heard her side yet we need
to save her yeah son she about to save
herself mark we haven't heard her side
she's about to come with the craziness
she's gonna be talking on mike
we're gonna get to watch it seductive as
[ __ ]
you know johnny depp with his whole
little oh i'm cool i'm mysterious i'm
whatever
wait till the [ __ ] throat
assassin
amber so what is your defense say what
what's your defense amber my my defense
not hire her
oh yeah sorry
i think she's gonna have that little mic
you know they got that little bob barker
mic oh
i think she can have that wrestling
between the tits okay
oh is this where this goes and i think
that she spits on it one time yeah
yo she gotta go crazy then she's
fighting for her life right now spit on
it one time rub it between the tits
maybe squeeze it and and just she all
she got to do is say that yeah yeah i
did all that and what
say that go up there and say yeah yeah
whatever he said i did it and he stayed
[Music]
you